[Music]
hello and welcome back to the break room
this is our daily live show that keeps
you updated on all the nerdy fandom news
that you need to know coming up on the
show today want some realm character
Roundup I hate that sentence an Untitled
Sony Marvel movie plans it's true and
Dave Batista future ROM comes oh my
goodness could you imagine could you be
would you be so enticed uh I'm Brandon
Barrack who cares across the table we
got the toy genre give me that Blade
Runner 2049 prequel that's a love story
oh yeah that's what I do why is he so
sad gay in that movie whoa I don't know
I don't want to see he's a real bad
robot be all right speaking on behalf of
all games we got John Costa hi I'm also
a gay robot oh delicious and next to me
right here we got our boy Tommy B you
people don't deserve me
you're right oh okay thank you that beer
looks great oh he's lit today don't get
it uh thanks to Blue chew all right oh
no no in a while they didn't pay for it
today stop taking him away okay
uh we got lots to get to today so let's
get right into it with the headlines
tickets
James Gunn has teased more information
about Batman and Superman in the
upcoming DCU he said that quote he's at
the Daily Planet I assume this is
Superman uh we're coming into a world
where superheroes exist and have existed
so does that mean Batman might be a
couple years older than Superman yes it
could be
such a structure that's how he said it
he said it like the way my high school
football coach used to get us excited
for games or he'd be like yes hey it
could be are they a good team they might
be
you think they've got it figured out how
to play against us
they might have that
is there any chance that they've worked
harder than us this week no sir no way
in hell they did oh motivational they
were who they thought we were no intend
that you know the thing that makes me
the happiest from that quote was that
this is a world where there have been
superheroes for a little while
um which I like it's not it's you know
it's we're not getting a lot of origin
stories for a lot of these characters
even the world is not getting in order
we're gonna just jump in to a world that
like hopefully already feels kind of
established if he's gonna play with that
as a concept like Flashpoint leaving
like ramifications like if the end of
everything is Flashpoint like it was
pretty strongly said in the announcement
will we have characters that are aware
of Another Universe I think he came out
and said no okay because that's my
curiosity if if we have Aquaman be this
like middle ground because I think Blue
Beetle they can nicely like wrap up and
tie in because they have time right and
I think flash they're probably going to
reshoot the ending or like reshape
things I think that there's going to be
like basically a Cascade event where
depending on how these do how much
they'll impact the future because we
have 2024 to decide they'll be shooting
these movies but we can kind of have
that maybe be like an echo so I'm really
curious about that I also think it's
kind of weird that people are so upset
about the idea of an older Batman than
Superman because I've never thought of
an alien physiology he needs to be the
same age as him same birthday same
birthday same age you gotta have the
mom's name and the birthday on the card
but I mean I think if you have like a 30
year old Batman and he's got like a a 10
year old kid that's not crazy if
Superman's like 30 and he's like 35 I
don't know it's just
it's not it's not too insane to me I
think it works and I love the idea of
you know superheroes existed so like you
have Superman going around New York and
they're like yeah Metropolis excuse me
they're like there's also in New York
explain that to me I don't know uh uh
but like yeah he's zipping around there
like yeah yeah we don't pretend it's the
kind of like the the bad guy he's our
favorite
um we kind of speculated this yesterday
or within the last two days uh that if
if the story they're telling with Batman
is with Damian Wayne and all that then
he should be older and if this is a year
one Superman then yeah it should
probably be a little bit I think it's
gonna be like a year three Superman uh I
think it's gonna be no no but I'm saying
like just I I'm not it's not semantics
there's a different tone of year three I
think he's gonna be a little bit more
established that's the only reason I'm
bringing up year three because Lex is a
childhood like you know faux friend but
I think he's going to be established as
that rivalry is already established
beyond the year One Tone and I also
think it's going to be a matter of the
reason they're doing the bat family I
think Beyond bringing in Damian Wayne is
it's going to be an already established
Nightwing it's gonna be an already
established perhaps Red Hood this allows
you to have a relationship with Joker
that's already fully formed so you can
use them or not this allows you to have
a fully I mean we've got Jared Leto back
he's back but it allows you to have
somehow Jared let her return it's that
the Batman that that can fit with
Justice League is going to be a little
softer and I think having Damian Wayne
be more intense and an assassin will be
a great mirror for the Justice League
we're gonna pull the rip cord on koi and
the DCU a little bit later in the show
so I'll be right now save some okay
juice them up boys save some of it next
headline folks Sony Pictures 2024
release slate listen Untitled Sony Slash
Marvel Universe movie it is currently
slated for release on July 12 2024 now
we personally at the channel we think
this could be Venom three yeah which
we're expecting to start shooting this
summer seems like the furthest Arena in
April 2022. that doesn't already have a
date I I've been speculating that we
will not have a standalone Spider Boy
movie before the end of Secret Wars I
think Spider-Man will be in the secret
world yeah I'm in there I don't know I
don't know I think they want that to I I
think I don't think it's gonna like Kang
Dynasty's gonna everything up and
then there's gonna be a standalone
Spider-Man movie that everyone's gonna
be like wait I thought this world
shattered and then like the post-credits
scene is going to be him getting sucked
into battle world or something sure but
I mean like I don't think we get to
stand alone Spider-Man movie because I
think the Sony Marvel relationship this
is just purely me speculating doing a
little wrestling booking of fantasy
booking of my own the relationship
started well they shook hands Civil War
it happens we see Spider-Man we're
making these three Standalone movies you
get a doctor strange you get an Iron Man
in your movie Sony it's going great we
love it it's a great partnership we get
in game it's beautiful everyone's crying
far from home oh it's great then we move
into this new territory and they're like
somebody's like well we're gonna make
some movies too they make their venom
movies everything's going well and then
you get like garbage and at the end of
it right Venom gets sucked into the MCU
Kevin feige is like wait what's
happening that way I gotta explain this
so then they have to add a little thing
at the end far from home they're like oh
it was down in Mexico and now he's back
it's all good and feige he's like oh we
got past that one and then he goes and
sees morbius and maybe a morbius and
he's like wait what is happening someone
and I think the relationship is a little
rough right now so they're like we'll
get back together after Secret Wars I
want I need Dave Franco and Seth Rogen
to make in the interview too so that
Sony gets hacked again
he's emailing Amy Pascal I like that
you're going with Dave Franco this time
oh yes sorry James James we don't want
you no no Dave Franco's ready I think uh
I think you're on the money and I also
think that it might be Andrew Garfield I
think they're I think they're
aggressively courting Andrew Garfield I
would love it and I think excuse me oh I
think he's doing so many great things
yeah I like those movies they're fun 90s
movies but I I honestly I think Tom
Hardy wants to play him another time and
then probably like go like he made him
to play with his kids like he made him
to like have that I think he probably
doesn't want to play that in forever so
you need to make it sooner and I also
think that if you're going to get Andrew
Garfield or Toby you should do it sooner
than later and Toby already has the the
messiness of Venom so I think it's
Andrew and I do think you're right about
Spider-Man and we'll get an older
College age like senior year of college
Spider-Man after all the chaos and Ken
can solve those Venom problems sure we
got a guy yeah yeah Spider-Man will be
in Marvel movies but we're not gonna
have a standalone Spider Boy movie until
after this is all done will Spider-Man
be in Phantom three
a spider well I think he thinks it's
Garfield I also think into the
spider-verse but comes across the
spider-verse and when they go through
the spider-verse in the third one it
goes to Mad Webb and there's live action
stuff well yeah and again we think this
is Venom three because like Madame Webb
has a release date uh uh uh Craven the
hunter has a release date so it's not
those we know those are still I think
those all connect though through
Spiderman and I think that we're gonna
see Venom be more impactful because
that's 20 24 that's a while away we
could have something happen with Madame
Webb and across through the spider-verse
that impacts all of this so like this
could be a big event thing that we don't
even know about okay okay as long as
both sides are talking to each other I
just hope they're happy as long as I
hear a lot of people who are talking
about craving
no no oh they are no oh yeah okay that's
interesting next headline looking for a
present for the ant stands in your life
how about the now
sorry how about the now totally real
book
at a new Marvel promo Paul Rudd presents
Scott Lang's Memoir it's very meta and
he calls it out uh which you can get
pre-orders in for right now uh the book
does not ship until September I already
looked at the website oh because I was
like oh do we need to read this ahead of
him it doesn't ship until September I
think they're writing the book oh my God
are they writing it one letter a day
well I don't know but yeah I really
don't think they're right what month is
it am I confused in February right okay
from May June July August September
that's eight months from you did the
math you did them I hope it's a time
travel joke like in in the book there's
Kang references from Kang Dynasty I know
like there's stuff that like jumps
through time well this is the book we
see him promoting in the trailers for
Ant-Man and the Wasps
he's had a book reading reading it uh so
you know the Blu-ray will be up by there
yeah yeah I was really hoping that we
would get the podcast that was
referenced in Miss Marvel where like
Scott Lang was doing a NPR style like
recap of what had happened in in game
still trying to put that is Terry Gross
do Cameo can we hire Terry Grossman I
would love Terry Bros we'll do like 55
cameos and get a full script Scott Wang
you told it all about your time in
prison but I want to know more about
your time instead of thanos's ass
well my gosh well Terry that's the book
yeah um the whole book's attello uh talk
about gross
I like that one we'll we'll go back to
that save that uh we also got a new
Ant-Man spot a teaser if you will for
the for those of you who want to see
this in 3D if you love to Avatar too you
can see Ant-Man and the one squads of
random in 3D in this trailer we see the
glowing ant farm from the lab uh that we
saw where they get the initial second if
you will the second uh we see this kind
of thing in the background it almost
looks like a map we think it's like an
ant farm but his little glowing ants
it's been pointed out in the videos you
watch the channel folks uh this new this
new trailer you kind of see that getting
sucked into the quantum realm uh and
they make a point of showing it in this
trailer and the fact that you see it
going in that could be an important
McGuffin for this movie right you don't
have ants uh huh they don't have they
don't have pants
maybe Quantum ants could we see Quantum
ants maybe you have to build tunnels I
mean there's all this I mean you know
these ant references in these movies of
course but this one especially with all
the ant-man's acting like ants and
making a tower true who knows I don't
know World War Z you just need to see
the movie already this is the MCU
property that references it's like uh
you know the thing that the person is
based on the most we're not getting a
lot of like uh well Spiderman doesn't
talk to spider we're not getting a lot
of spider stuff you get some Panthers
I'll take it wet yeah it's all ants
that's right she doesn't talk to wasps
as far as I know I think he's also the
character that probably I mean later he
starts not building a suit out of iron
let me tell you it is way too heavy he
did it once yeah I think you're right I
think and even the comic books because
Spider-Man like has a spider totem thing
but it's not a spider based as Ant-Man
Captain America is talking about America
that's true
and it's all over him it's all over yeah
it's pretty Spangled it's all over him I
wish Ant-Man talked to real ants
I wish I could talk to my aunts oh well
they did they they all got on a train
together one day and that train careened
off the side
yeah oh my gosh it was an avalanche
that was terrible that one's worth Kim
Duncan we love your work on the Spurs
but we're never going to talk about
Percy Jackson
uh yeah you heard it from Tommy's mouth
also trash bags we have to this is I'm
kind of angry about this okay well
that's because John hasn't finished and
door uh but trash bag has just finished
Andor yes
I watched 11 episodes
for Andor I started watching it and I
just don't care about menorah's
character and one way yeah
it accelerates so beautiful hopefully
the the pacing I gotta watch okay I'm
working on it I haven't said it on the
channel in a while apologize
and John I do apologize thank you thank
you for your candor about Andor I was
not trying to be candid about it Brandon
out at me you were at it I apologize for
that Preston Jones they need garbage
plates and Guardians they need garbage
plates anywhere the most delicious of
all Cuisine the garbage place the
official garbage plate is the official
dish of Rochester New York it's not a
secret what is the garbage plate our
garbage plate is macaroni home fries uh
either hot dogs or cheeseburgers on top
with a meat sauce onions and mustard let
me tell you you eat one of those you
feel like you swallowed a bowling ball
uh both inside and out yeah that saved
me a lot of money on bowling balls I
mean I heart surgeons in Rochester oh we
don't have any there they just drop
everyone I'm out of here people we have
what's called a heart attack and when it
starts to come on you just walk over the
edge and flop in okay yeah it's like a
very self-serving well on that now let's
get into our main discussion today we
got this new Ant-Man uh and the WASP
quantumania spot you know we're in that
these are the dark times folks uh the
movie's a couple weeks away uh they're
gonna keep putting out these little
teasers they're gonna give us a little
more juice each one to tease us more to
get us into those theaters
uh we don't want to spoil the movie too
much we can't we haven't seen it yet but
like we do want to kind of take this
moment to take a register of these weird
Quantum realm people that we got
involved those little side characters
they're gonna play a role in this uh
movie so in this most recent trailer we
got our first look at the character Zeb
who's being played by David Des malcian
but you might know from the there's a
great photo of yeah goopy it's goofy
this is the head of Zeb uh let me think
it looks like some sort of a goop in his
in his in a jar yeah yeah let me let me
tell you guys uh I don't want to
cross-pollinate our platforms sooner so
I have a pretty Dynamite theory about
the uh QR Quantum realm residence coming
out on Rogue Theory uh this week I want
to invite you all to watch on Saturday
because I've got some thoughts on Zeb uh
I've got some rules for the quantum
realm a QR code if you will oh
that I I think is going to blow do I
have to download an app gen Z loves the
Q now just open your photo what happened
just live through a pandemic we all know
how to do it that's where all the menu
um I want to talk about this guy yeah
talk about Zach because we were talking
about it earlier he's super goopy which
is kind of weird uh different than a lot
of the other Quantum realm characters
that we've seen so far but he's also
being voiced by someone who's in the
Ant-Man in the first two right but
confirm that that character is not
coming back for this one I prefer some
crossover there so when I have talked
about this so I I don't know where
you're going with that but like
you know uh Luis we're not getting
change watch your tone
that's one gentlemen don't make me count
to three gentlemen you know uh what we
saw with Modoc slash yellowjacket slash
Darren cross he gets sucked into the
quantum realm and he becomes all this
super disfigured and then like put him
inside of this like I feel like they put
him in his little body right his body
made out of metal it feels like they
like set him in there you know what I
mean he's also really goopy right so we
were talking earlier yeah if you say
goofy one more time
based on Frank goofy is the new moist
yeah
those are based on Frank but also like
he stretched he's deformed he's a
different shape he like if you look at
his face he looks well we only got one
good shot all his all his friends I'm
trying to say is
what if
Zeb what if Zeb is
just like a pre-modoch you know what I
mean you know what I mean you suck
yourself brought in he is sucked in the
quantum Realm by mistake and this is
sort of like you know I remember the
first time got killed by a gooby right
yeah Frank oh that's not character yeah
so there it is there is potential for a
transformation to this world where they
could have a Quantum realm because that
was that rumor forever ago that the
Fantastic Four were stuck in that little
right so what if people get trapped in
the quantum reality yeah and some don't
have the physiology but the Fantastic
Four dude well yeah and you know one of
the things we talked about a couple
weeks ago was that the
um people who use pin particles like
start making them in their body that's a
comic book right so if you it's a comic
book thing thank you so if you if you
assume all these folks get trapped in
the quantum realm and they they like go
through Cassie's weird device
but you've got David despaci and just
like he came over to like drop some mail
off or something like that and he'd get
sucked in and he doesn't have the
physiology that the pims do I mean it's
Zeb now please use my incredible why is
Darren cross not in the quantum realm
being like please call me Darren well a
we don't know that yet uh that could be
true B with Darren cross you bring up a
good point right uh Frank is the
gentleman we saw in the first Ant-Man he
worked for Jan cross he questioned him
Jerry cross give him a little zap with
the still being evolved to pin particles
and he was turned into a goo that was
moving so still alive and flushed him uh
when Darren cross enters the quantum
realm it's not through Pym particles
okay it's through cross particles and
stuff he's developed he's in the Yellow
Jacket suit now remember his but Frank
is also cross particles uh Frank is uh
uh his this is but this is like the late
stage that are actually working but they
only work if the organic materials
inside of a suit foreign
particles not pimp particles so that
could deform his body as he goes down
because when his arm is the first one
yeah the first one he goes into the he
goes subatomic into Yellow Jackets
regulator to force that to happen he's
not shooting out pin particles like red
red red red he's just like so whatever
happened to Derek Ross he it's the the
cross particles that brought him down so
yeah he's probably like deformed and I
think the metallicness of his body is
maybe his own suit that he's like fused
with yeah and Kang gave whatever Tech he
had he's like oh this is the best thing
it's like this is the best I could do uh
but you're thinking that Zeb could be
the same I think he might have been yeah
he might have been sucking too and then
they're like walking around the quantum
realm and he's like hey
is watch Rogue Theory and it's all gonna
make well we're on this show well
basically yeah I can't spoil my rogue
Theory I want to say so much but I gave
my heart out to that show you know and I
don't want to drop into the heart attack
pit yet so it's good it's hurtful well
let's talk about another uh Quantum
person we have and again the question is
did all these people get sucked in or
some of them born there organically
gotta be there's a huge Society there I
would I don't think everyone unless Kang
brought in a whole neighborhood
sorry to Jump Ahead here a little bit
but like this character krylar Lord
krylar you know this is Bill Murray's
character you remember
um not to bring politics into this but
I'm going to
um the main Senator elect election in
2020 was between uh I can't remember her
name Susan Collins Susan Collins and and
the Challenger right Susan Collins is
the incumbent Susan Collins ran all
these ads about how she was from Maine
she's born and raised in Maine and her
opponent was not even though her
opponent like moved there when they were
like 10 or whatever
um
I think that Bill Murray is playing this
guy Lord kreiler who's the governor of
Axia which is this community within the
quantum realm that we're talking about I
have to think that first of all the
society is built so built up so much
that feels like people have been here
for Generations I also kind of think
like he might be some sort of like you
know Quantum realm purist who is like
I've been here for a long time but for
me for governor he has these Sinister
intentions
whereas Janet right his sort of like
antithesis in this movie was a visitor
and came in and had to do what if going
off your theory he is a you know
loyalist to the people that were born
there and the goop people he wants to
keep so the group people come in and
he's like no no you're goopy wouldn't
you I mean a bunch of groupers came to
Earth you'd be like I don't want I don't
want to turn this back into politics 101
but I do want to point out that that
prior to a democracy a governor is an
appointed position so I don't know that
bill ran in a free democratic election
in the quantum realm governor of life or
in Axia he may have been named Governor
he may have named himself Governor or
maybe someone just went out of governor
and he was like oh my God I'm going to
keep that well he does go by Lord grylar
and considered a governor so I don't
know who knows uh now yeah he could also
be a small version of one of the like
the the bigger beings like The Collector
and The Grandmaster yeah
because the Elder the universe are are
generally you know Larger than Life but
it would make sense that it'd be smaller
ones too so and the casting wise is very
akin to your Benicio del Toros and your
Jeff Goldbergs so there could be
something to him being one of that type
of leader that is self-appointed was he
hiding from Gore this whole time or
Alexis
well I mean they've established like
eternity and we saw the room that had a
bunch of other of those kind of elderly
that's a funny idea one of those like
hiding you know we've seen concept art
we know there was a deleted scene
the Grand Master I was always wondering
if that was him going and being like Oh
you're not a God and they would kind of
have that Line in the Sand because we
don't really know if the elders are
considered gods in this universe like
the hierarchy of power has to change
yeah we have to know isn't it God right
just sort of like a higher being I think
Marvel maybe Marvel does have a line
there but I would think like they have
better technology are they better more
more powerful right two Mortals right
like someone with immortality which the
Elders of the universe kind of have
um would be a God I think but what would
Gore be hunting in his purview because
he he killed a literal God of like myth
immediately so and we also don't know
about that I talk about all the time of
the heavens and hells and all those
things like is that going to be
something they discuss and draw lines in
Pocket Dimensions we're gonna get Gore
uh trying to kill uh Mephisto in iron
heart that's gonna be the storyline
I wrote in there somewhere uh now one
other thing to bring out Bring up about
Lord kriler is they're really leaning
heavy on the news and the kind of press
for this movie that like there's some
sort of weird relationship between Janet
Van Dyne and Lord kriler I mean she was
down there long enough she can do
whatever she wants her husband didn't
come to get her so what are you gonna do
uh she thought she was on her own it's
it's Caster way down there and you know
it's interesting we there's the the
Comic Con trailer that never got
released where he goes Janet Janet and
we never
hear that line of dialogue the only
thing we've seen from him is the one
shot and that first trailer we haven't
seen him in any of the TV spots
um we've heard personally any rock stars
that like Janet is going to feature a
lot more heavily in this movie obviously
in the first two she wasn't really in
those that much
um but it seems like this relationship
is going to be really kind of front and
center especially when it comes to
putting a wedge between hope and Janet
sure right well I'm like very little
Hank in the trailers we've had one live
on Hank I just saved bucks that's it it
is interesting how we're this close to
release and we haven't really had a lot
of the stuff we saw the longest to go
and we've had all the alternate lines
from Kang the alternate launch from Kang
make me think we're gonna meet multiple
kangs and those actually might be
different they're gonna repeat this it's
crazy I honestly think we're gonna get
my fancy a scene where that's like I've
heard it's the anti-doctor stranger yeah
yeah so I can see that happening but
it's weird that there's a lot of full-on
scenes we haven't seen since July the
new one today was crazy when he was like
Whopper Whopper Whopper Whopper Whopper
Whopper Whopper Whopper
now Lord cry live does exist in the
comics uh he's an alien scientist of the
microverse which is kind of the quantum
realm in the comics he served uh the
warlord visas and had a machine capable
of physically generating someone's
deepest fear whoa uh scarecrow that's
right that's right or a popular a
popular device
thank you Bogarts you got to imagine
something funny and then throw a shoe
too uh krylar assisted also assisted the
Hulk in fighting a doppelganger of his
but it was later killed by business no
that's R.I.P Lord cry live now another
another character we've seen very little
love uh is quas quays squash we're gonna
go with quas yes this is played by
William Jackson you know I'm from
mid-summer and the good place and tons
of other stuff now there is speculation
that this could be the hero Quasar
um we don't know that for sure in the
comics Quasar is also known as Wendell
Von a okay Marvel boy and later Marvel
man different
or what happened no matter how young
Marvel lady
did the Marvel if you will wow that's
really good place uh and the craziness
been around he's Affiliated over time
with the Avengers he was everyone's been
an adventure in the comics book uh he
was in sword at one point uh part of
Project Pegasus which has been mentioned
in the MCU before so we don't know you
know there we kind of talked around like
this could be a child of king I don't
know uh that's not who Quasar is in the
comments but again we don't know that
this is Quasar people just assuming that
maybe it is because it Quasar is a
character who fits into Cosmic Marvel
and even though this is quantum realm
this is Cosmic marble in a lot of ways
yeah I love that uh that was mt's theory
that he had on slack for a long time
yeah
um and it still could be true totally
well you know everyone was saying
William Jackson Harper is being cast as
read
probably not the case
um
I do think you don't cast an actor like
that I mean I know we got Lake Bell for
like a half a second in
um forever I do think William Jackson
Harper at this point is maybe like a
little bit more well known than her
um I don't think you cast William
Jackson Harper as like a guy off to the
side I also think that where he is in
his career he wouldn't want to
necessarily I could see him wanting to
LEAP from TV to a franchise I could see
like where he just is this is I don't
think he would want it to be a one-off
like it'd be good exposure but I know
though I don't know if they say we got
you for one
of we've seen Michelle yo play multiple
characters in The MCA and a couple other
folks but I like the Kazar idea just
because Quasar uh just because it is
that type of character and and we are
going more Cosmic with you know the
beyonder I think coming in secret Wars
in those things so I could see him being
that it's just we have no context in a
Direction so it could honestly like a
guy with one line but I hope it's not
well it does kind of seem like that
right from this photo oh we only have
one photo but it does kind of seem like
he's going to be like one of the Freedom
Fighters with like Six Flags the generic
Freedom Fighter outfit yeah yeah
um uh I hope he is a A Reed Richards and
every couple of movies between now and
Fantastic Four they introduce a red
ridges and kill him and then have the
council which one is it gonna be and
then the council of reads is all those
actors coming back in secret yes
and it's always the people who are
rumored we're gonna get Adam Driver yeah
uh Pedro pascals
[Laughter]
oh my God two oh my God I'm fantastic
there's just a green room that moves
around La and it just lets the actors
sit in the chair and play a council of
Reed members yeah you sit down and they
take uh 1700 photos of your body like we
got you you're good the Doom portal is
real it's just Kevin foggy casting
actors uh well speaking of the Freedom
Fighters we have gen Torah this is John
his favorite character uh she is the
leader of the Freedom Fighters does she
have like cybernetic implants I don't
know this is like both organic and
cybernet is like spidery I don't know
yeah this looked like it could have been
a shot from like life or yeah you know
the eternals or something very strange
um yeah they're called the Freedom
Fighters a weird name I think for the
quantum Roma give it a cool Quantum
meaning can I say something yeah
first of all let me allow me to defend
the woman that we've discussed here
today as the men all Preen crow in her
appearance I think
every band on this Fisher panel
writing us right now what's happening
let me come to her rescue no uh uh in
defense I think that a lot of these
names are fake uh oh I think uh the
Freedom Fighters is gonna be a fake name
I think firefighters is pretty generic I
think so I think Lord krylar is a as a
Mr act like he may be introduced as Lord
kreiler I believe that that character
will be someone different someone from
earth616 that has gone into the quantum
realm I I like the idea of him being
like a Quantum realm purist of like I
have been around here the longest but I
also like to you has Martha ever done
the Trope of like the person comes in
and kills the person and it replaces the
person that calls himself the person can
you imagine Bill Murray yeah I guess a
little bit but flipped like if you
imagine Bill Murray is from 616. somehow
gets trapped in the quantum sees someone
who like looks vaguely like him kills
him assumes his personality and his role
it's on Draper yeah yes I like it I just
think we're being a like I think that
like well none of them said it's all
done and like tiny little there's a
press release that's what I'm saying
we've got no footage of most of it I'm
agreeing with you because like all of
our footage is conjecture and I think
yeah and I think in the sense of like
it's not a lie it's just not the full
story sure we want to be misled yeah
please you know in the way that like in
the trailers they'll show things from
reverse angles or it's backwards or out
of sequence unless all Marvel trailers
be the Hulk and like running with a fake
team like if they just give us the tone
via trailer and then let the movie be a
surprise because then everyone can
scrutinize and find Easter eggs but then
you actually get an experience in the
movie yeah I think they should it's a
great time to talk about new Rockstar's
newest Channel The Deep dive launching
on February 17th one of the videos
coming out on the channel is going to
explore how trailers lie to us Eric did
a ton of research put together this like
kind of like incredible uh really
detailed piece of like trailer editing
versus movies versus you know
intentionality versus this just got cut
from the movie
um I would tell you to go watch it but
you can't yeah but I have and it's great
so February 17th go ahead and subscribe
to the flex on two weeks yeah so you
don't miss it uh we also have uh oh I
can't believe you wrote this in the
description
we have uh what we're calling swirl head
light face guy uh we saw this person in
an early trailer we haven't heard a
voice we don't really have a name for
this person okay there's this moment
in another trailer we see Kang putting
like a ball inside of a device now if
you turn that device is like a tube yeah
we're seeing from the side if you turned
it it would look like a little circle
like that oh and it could be that
Whitehead guy it could be he's
activating light heading that's all I'm
saying it could be that way when I am
right I will wreak havoc at this office
okay I will destroy John you know I
think and this is my fault he's coming
around I was pretty sure the show it's
my fault for not
um fully stamping this out I do think we
have a shot of that same device in a
later trailer and it's sort that's what
I'm saying I wish I had show us now
um but one of the things you were saying
was that uh you were saying that this
could be Zeb it could also be Zeb
because all of Zeb we saw was zeb's
house oh zeb's dead babe his absolutely
and for me I think Modoc has like a
little carrier that they put his weird
head in maybe so I like this idea that
could also be sad
weird goopy head gets put on that body I
don't know I would love if dust
monitoring gets to evolve like a Pokemon
that's Charizard we also have the
forearm bartender
you know you got forearms you're
supposed to be a bartender I think this
scene is going to be more important than
me expect it's like we saw those shots
in Multiverse of Madness trailer of like
uh doctor strange and
um America and uh
and opening that thing we saw the watch
on the thing we're like what is that and
it was the watch was a key and it was
opening
um to get the book of Ashanti all that
kind of stuff I think later on in the
trailer we see them sort of like opening
a portal in a world that looks
relatively similar I think the Freedom
Fighters have taken them to like their
Speakeasy hangout place and they're
gonna like portal them to some kind of
really pivotal location in the quantum
realm
um I think this is like a late second
act moment wonderful I would assume that
Speakeasy is like an anti-scumin
villainy Cantina where it's a place Ken
can't see yeah so maybe it's a place
like beyond the his his ability to
interact with so they have like a place
out of time because the Freedom Fighters
are gonna need a safe haven and
presumably from Kang place but yeah I
think a place beyond Kang is that
foreign
already this is Darren Cross or at least
his face uh and then at some point he
gets this little body I think I give him
a mouth where he's scowling I just I
will say if you bring that image up one
more time uh human proportioned hands
yeah arms yeah that's all our kids
spaced way out yeah
just to put your sort of yeah to put
your sort of yellow jacket Theory all it
tied it a bow right like you know they
got shrunk first and then he got down
one arm goes in first yeah and then it
kind of all happens quickly so then
maybe he's just like goopy boy has to
get a shell but the arm stays you got to
go around the arms
am I being transformed into anything I
want my thumbs I got a dog he doesn't
have thumbs changes everything yeah it's
a big difference there's a big
difference now I also also think Modoc
is going to be our classic Marvel moment
where you have like the joke the joke of
the name moment uh in no way home this
was like uh your name's Otto Octavius
uh spider Spider-Man's always making
this joke right they did it Infinity War
when he's like oh Doctor Strange we're
using our superhero names
um
yes Marvel and DC and all comic books
have silly names guys we get it uh this
will be the joke name moment of the
movie when we when the name Modoc is
revealed but it will not stand for the
traditional machine organism designed
only for killing uh it'll have some
other Goofy name and Darren cross will
hate being called modak and they'll be
like don't tell me that my name is
Darren cross and like whatever Modoc
yeah I could see Darren Darren cross
like in the first anime movie like was
so full of himself and thought it was
like the Savory of the Universe I could
see him being my trunk down to the
quantum I was like who are you no one
cares and he's just like really so it
makes that a hard space to be like
intense Darren cross was also constantly
being gaslit because he was told that
like pin particles don't exist and they
did it well and he was going crazy
because he had crossed particles yes uh
messing with his brain because you're
free Darren cross yes he does nothing
wrong oh my God the reason Ant-Man has a
helmet is because the pin particles will
drive you insane actually
pimp kind of a dick yes hey he's
creating this pin particles
drove me crazy and I beat the out
of my wife in the comics save it for our
six hour live stream after this are the
bad guys getting a bad rap in the MCU
deep dive well we'll discuss we'll
discuss that more but first be sure to
check out nerd riot.shop where we have
our latest merch designs based on
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania they're
up for Sarah now I'm wearing one of them
this one says lost time and it's
ant-man's head and and it's shrinking oh
now I see it John's wearing a a hoodie
covered in dog hair oh my God turn back
around I didn't know much dog hair
design on the front where you buy merch
From Nerd Riot dive shop it will not be
covered it comes preheats it does now
you might be saying to yourself I've
heard you guys say new rockstars merch
come all the time what's nerd right.shop
well we're working more closely with our
merch Partners at nerd Riot to bring you
more awesome merch based on new rock
stars and the different fandoms that we
all love so part of that partnership we
got a new link nerdright.shop you'll
love it Mt even helped design one of the
quantum Mania shirts featuring Kang it's
the Vitruvian King wait Jessica and
are you interrupting my yeah
she's got Merchants are also wearing
some merch she does not want to be
called out right now she's wearing our
uh uh our black panther wakanda forever
sharing she's working on her re-break
term as we speak uh you could still get
this shirt at nerd riot.champ you can
get all of our awesome be gone
today quantumania merch and if you order
now you can get it in time for opening
weekend we rarely have our shirts ahead
of time we're on the ball this time
folks uh really nice yeah we're to the
theater you see another person wearing
the shirt be like
you
see you Jake Sally this is this is like
Peak excitement for this movie yeah and
and a little bit after the movie comes
out but then we're gonna be like all
talking about guardians galaxy volume
three and we'll have an emerge for that
like while we're super excited about it
this this shirt will live on as time
moves forward what do you guys think we
get before we leave the quantum realm uh
what do you think we get in the Super
Bowl trailer the days leading up to them
well hold your board oh well I might
have skipped we're gonna talk about
Super Bowl stuff check out all the merch
options at nerdright.com you did it
supports the channel uh hey
what's up
guys I'm a time traveler and I jump back
in my body too soon uh the Super Bowl's
coming up it's in a couple of weeks it's
the Sunday before Quantum media comes
out if that's how you live your life
like I do a week from um
it'll be a week from that yeah so it's
Sunday so we'll have the last of us
after show and then there'll be no show
Monday so there'll be no opportunity for
us to talk about these things Tommy no I
mean no tell me no the break room is
going to be live what after the Super
Bowl talking about all of the trailers
who will be there I don't exactly know
yet I'll be drunk suffering massive
gambling losses Oh no just get more pit
ready it's horrible we're gonna be right
here uh uh after the Super Bowl I don't
know exactly what time that moves get
that movie it's a movie you know
anything rigged just like a movie John
scripted we don't know what time it's
gonna end it could go into overtime who
knows we do know we're getting a bunch
of trailers and we're going to want to
talk about them as soon as that ends
Eric Voss is going to have his own
reactions to specific trailers uh that
we'll put out probably during the Super
Bowl but after the Super Bowl we're
going to be here talking about all of
them
um in one place convenient for you
um and I just want to kind of go over
you know what trailers we're expecting
and then maybe we could talk about what
we kind of think we'll get out of them
the one that I'm the most excited about
I know this is crazy I'm really excited
for the Marvels too we'll get to that
second
The Flash
cringe everyone has said this is the
greatest show they're talking about this
movie a lot of all time and I just want
to know if I should buy into the hype or
if it's hyperbole
um I just if I see the trailer I'll be
like oh yeah that looks like it's going
to be one of the greatest superhero
movies of all time I mean maybe they'll
cut a bad trailer but Warner Brothers
historically was a man of steel trailers
good it basically shows a popular song
or do they just go school yeah you're
right Suicide Squad trailer really good
yeah yeah well I mean do they use a song
like
um yeah so I I think like we don't
really know too much about the plot of
this movie we got some stuff at DC
fandom in 2020 but if I'm being honest
it's been two and a half years I don't
really know that there's a Batman yeah
and there's no loss we got a couple
Batmans Superman there was two flashes
and a couple shots
um so I'm really excited to just have
more about this to talk about
um and and see what this movie's gonna
be all about okay I'm thrilled that'll
be a good one yeah
um for Universal that was Warner
Brothers we're only expecting uh maybe
that'll give us something from Shazam
that we've already seen before but
really The Flash uh these sort of
pre-announced that they're gonna put
that trailer out from Universal on the
10th so a couple days before the Super
Bowl Universal having this big event for
fast 10. uh and then they're gonna have
a trailer uh at the Super Bowl yeah
we're gonna talk about that probably on
Friday before the Super Bowl um if we
can get our hands on it before we go
live
um
we're also getting a like a 15 second
cocaine bear 15 seconds before before
the game okay that's not very good it's
a low budget movie they only paid for 15
seconds before the game so if you want
to see more about cocaine it would be a
great if it's a 15 second trailer on
cocaine and it's like if you slow it
down
marketing yeah I like that idea I'll say
in 15 seconds is pretty step done this
is a messy cocaine that's right yeah
we're also hearing probably no Mario
yeah Mario stuff they might they don't
they don't need it I don't think they
need to pay the the Super Bowl prices I
think this that movie's gonna do yeah
yeah yeah can you skip this section real
fast uh for Paramount we're expecting
Scream Six uh Whitney was in the office
earlier very exciting uh it's the next
movie too Dungeons and Dragons honor
among among Thieves Tommy's excited
about Transformers rise of the beast wow
a pretty good lineup we're not expecting
which is what I would be most hyped for
is Mission Impossible dead reckoning
part one we've seen a couple of things
from that movie we've seen some like
weird featurettes and some like crazy
stuff
but boy those movies especially after
after topio Maverick like I'm ready for
for more Tom uh Cruz Tom Foolery
um we're not expecting anything from
Sony so don't expect a trailer for
morbius too
uh craving the hunter Madam Webb any of
those projects
um and according to deadline we might be
getting trailers for John Wick chapter 4
or Creed 3. they reach out to those
Studios for comment and didn't hear back
we already have trailers for both of
those we do something like Creed 3 is
the most on brand audience though it is
two weeks after that it drops yeah I put
some money not a lot because of gambling
on the Super Bowl but I would say some
money creepy yeah uh yeah we should go
over our Super Bowl bets in that post
show too yeah that worked out you
cleaned up and who's got to find a new
place to live now that people are
talking about the fact that not only is
Michael B Jordan directing Creed 3 as
well as starring in it but it's the
first sports movie to use IMAX cameras
in the boxing ring
no one's talking about that okay
apparently they gotta hide everything
they don't want Crystal Clear that's
going to be so insane have you ever seen
the outtakes of like how bad the boxing
really looks oh it's like it's like the
like the hooks are like this I do love
the story right that a Stallone punched
the out of Michael B Jordan when
they were filming the first movie if
only that was an IMAX yeah but like
that's what's intense about this is like
the I mean Dolph Lundgren hit him so
hard he went in the hospital like the
violence on these movies can be insane
so I'm really curious about in IMAX what
that's going to be and it's also like
the trilogy I think that most people are
waiting for like I'm more excited for
creed than most things so it's
surprising that like the word of mouth
hasn't gotten past that trailer to me so
I don't know 323 is not that far when
people are going to see Jonathan majors
in quantumania and they're gonna be like
oh he's gonna be on this creeping yeah
yeah let's go
um for as for Disney uh we're getting
trailers for The Little Mermaid so they
could describe that as a teaser okay too
so it's like this already and I don't
know if it's gonna but that wasn't even
really a teaser right that was like part
of a scene right well it was a teaser in
that it was a true teaser where it was
like I don't want to see the Earth
just you know
that was the biggest moment I thought
from d23 was how like stunning that
footage was because we knew what to
expect for a lot of stuff and a lot of
the reveals were great but I think we
were all struck by Little Mermaid so I
really want more so I'm excited for that
yeah uh we're getting a trailer for
Pixar's Elemental
um which is like uh for me seems sort of
inside outie
um about uh two elements I think Fire
and Water right falling in love
um
hearing possibly another trailer for uh
Indiana Jones in the dial of Destiny
very exciting and then we are getting
spots for Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania and Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 yes please
um hearing possibly we might get
something for the Marvels too
um I don't quite understand how uh the
it's possibly right like you'd think
that they would have their spots all
sort of locked in maybe it's like if the
game runs long or whatever they got they
got the spots but they don't know what
they want to put out yeah right
um I think that's where they're at and
the Marvels is very interesting because
I think everyone who saw the footage of
d23 was very surprised by it was like oh
this looks great let's put this out like
let's get the head going for this movie
they haven't revealed anything yeah and
that's due for the summer July yeah as a
reminder last year we got the Multiverse
of Madness trailer that had Patrick
Stewart in it big moment
um the year before that we had a trailer
for Falcon in the Winter Soldier which
was pretty cool the year before that I
work in new rockstars the work with the
year before that we got that tease of
One Division Loki and Falcon water
Soldier but this year we're not
expecting anything from Secret Invasion
I don't think that show exists it's so
secret
um so secret I would love some other
Disney plus stuff uh like a Loki
something or other but they're not
giving us the secret Invasion I did not
expect I want the secret secret Invasion
trailer it looks like it's a trailer for
something else and then yeah
and then Loki's changes and like and
you're like oh yes do something like
that that's another free one for you
feige so we'll be here we'll be here
after the game late night on Sunday
talking about all this stuff we're also
gonna be putting out our Last of Us
episode I think five uh after show that
night yeah we'll see you back on Tuesday
of that week to get excited
when we get to it but yeah gonna be a
busy Sunday busy Sunday
has been in his feelings lately about
his acting careers oh yeah espresso
desire to be in a rom-com oh interesting
I've gathered three experts to be in my
writer's room to help me flesh out a few
Batista rom-com ideas I've cooked up
because we were the three people that
James Gunn was Consulting on yeah yeah
it's amazing that I have now brought you
guys you thought of some ideas yeah for
Iran comfortable yeah because yeah this
was kind of a funny headline we saw he
was kind of complaining very thirsty
yeah do not play the graphics do not
play the graphics
there it is
jaw unhinges like a cobra I don't even
know who's on the far right I've
completely forgot I hate it uh yeah he's
kind of like begging to be in a rom-com
when he put it as like am I not pretty
enough for you he didn't say that he's
like I look at the way that we've all
gone on Instagram and being like do I
look okay and everyone has to be like
yeah you look great I feel so it feels
so gross in this outfit
pitch okay so this is a picture oh we're
ready this is the first we're gonna
pitch us and we're gonna help you with
this I don't need you to go should I
call somebody just stop screwing up the
title is called with this ring oh okay
beautiful classic bowel yeah Dave
Batista is Caleb oh a local journalist
who wants to get engaged to his fiance
Fiona wow played by Rachel McAdams she
also played Christine Palmer John I
don't know okay the only problem is
Fiona's parents won't approve of Caleb
unless he buys a huge sparkling wedding
oh okay Caleb has no choice but to turn
to a life of MMA fighting and that is a
bloody underground fight to the death
tournament with a one million dollar
prize oh that doesn't that sounds like
uh sort of a more of an action yeah that
doesn't sound like a rom-com as much
okay well you know I have a few
okay this one that's what it's called
Second Chance oh okay okay Dave Batista
plays Nolan a local journalist who wants
to get engaged to his fiancee played by
Andy McDowell the only problem that's
some interesting casting Megan the only
problem is Megan's parents are dark
magic Wizards who have raised an army of
Undead
ex-conscious Nolan must play judge jury
and sexecutioner in this gory blood bath
that asks do we ever really get a second
chance why why do they have to be
ex-cons when they're because it's the
second chance
okay second chance this is actually
great I I will say a lot of blood still
okay I think this one's you know like
I've had a couple friends who's tried to
set up movies at like lifetime yeah or
whatever
this is a true story uh my friend did a
treatment for a lifetime and they said
can't have a mom with cancer too sad oh
she said so I think the blood is like
you know what if it's on Netflix and
Zack Snyder directs it because they're
friends
it's not a bad idea I have a few more
that I think are maybe a little more in
the Wheelhouse that we're asking for
okay I do want to remind everyone
tomorrow we've got a sadistic Super Chat
no I don't know
I'm kind of glad super chants have been
a little light today they've been great
everyone who did and we appreciate it I
hope that's because you're all saving
your shackles unpronounceable say happy
pre-friday thank you Christian I know he
says
you're in I don't believe
I mean you're in uh all right this next
title is called play and it's safe okay
Dave Batista is Preston a local
journalist who wants to get engaged to
his fiancee Florence played by Kelly
McDonald this is this is a much better
thing the only problem is Florence is
locked away in an Intergalactic safe
deposit box after being kidnapped by Mr
blister a sentient bubbling movement is
a lab by Dr nasty would you played by
Patrick Stewart Preston played by played
by or
is Patrick Stewart actually he may be
Preston must travel through time and
space to release the flow oh man
a lot of goop today all right if you
guys don't like that this is the last
idea I have and then I'm feeling really
embarrassed that I even worked I mean I
spent
15 minutes okay writing these well you
came to your three best friends your
writer's room yes I guess
you're right you're right no this
feedback is good I'll watch back after
we air this okay I will watch back and
I'll take these notes okay my last
suggestion never judge a book oh smart
Dave Batista is Chase a local journalist
who is leading a book burning effort in
the conservative sector of Praxis prime
a mere Dimension that exists in the
brains of parasite infected sheep he
desperately wants to get engaged to
Corpus Christi a half man half bar stool
played by succession breakout star
Matthew McFadden okay can chase finally
make an honest stool of Corpus Christi
or will the Librarians a rogue gang of
synthetic pleasure droids who seek only
who speak only in the Dewey Decimal
System destroy his happily ever after
honestly for me that's the one that is
yeah Corpus Christi's in the chat guys
wow never judge a book is what we're
calling this one huh yeah I like the
last one I think that's your best chance
yeah thanks it's not that is because it
does come around we got pleasure droids
I'll be honest
that was the one I was hoping you guys
would oh okay all right best for last
week so uh David Batista we know you're
listening if you like any of the other
representation yeah we're going to get
you in a straightforward rom-com this
year enough with the action enough with
the Thrillers enough with the Sci-Fi
we're doing straightforward ROM crom
they have a little bit of all of those I
think I don't I don't think I wouldn't
call it pleasure yeah I think uh like
Andy bushetty I'm a master of tone as
well he's got a direct Superman like you
wouldn't believe oh I'm sorry I do
apologize we didn't put it in the script
we do have a little bit of time yes if
you want to talk turn them loose all
right we don't have any kind of
structure
I think I think Jessica's off to the
side saying no
okay give me we got six minutes I just
need two your biggest thing that
surprised us was you said you think Andy
machete will be directing I think he's
gonna direct your mid legs okay let's
start with Superman Legacy what I'm most
excited about of this experience we're
gonna start Superman Legacy if anyone
can do it faster yeah that's what that's
we're here let's see if I can get to
roll 10 at a reasonable time all right
so Superman Legacy which is me okay
Superman Legacy I'm most excited about
because we're getting an All-Star
Superman take we saw that in the imagery
it's called Superman Legacy I don't
think it's about him dying I don't think
that's about the state of what Superman
ends at I think it's about him building
a legacy him growing as a person and
growing as a character I think we're
gonna get Jimmy we're gonna get Daily
Planet we're doing all those things that
we want for the heart of Superman I
think it's really important that right
now as the world is so dark as
everything is so despairing we do get
the Superman and bright red trunks
Superman was invented in 1938 40 years
for the poll uh wet pole the trunks pull
oh yeah I did okay uh Superman has been
since 1938 four year four World War II
we were in the thick of a depression
right now is probably one of the worst
times America has gone through now we
need Superman more than ever so I want a
bright shining Superman Allah All-Star
Superman and I think that we need him
now more than ever I think a slightly
younger take is gonna work and I think
the way they're building this is
absolutely the right move for DC going
over to the authority The Authority is a
really interesting take because you're
going to have a team of characters that
are a lot like the Justice League but
are like an anti-justice Justice League
and you have the suicide squad already
so building in a character set that is
already a commentary on these characters
that are a commentary on the DC universe
itself is fascinatingly meta because the
authority was a wild storm imprint that
was a commentary in DC that then merged
into DC so this is actually doing a
thing that is happening in the comic
books next month there's going to be a
book called uh Waller versus the
wildstorm and that is going to be about
bringing wildstorm into the comic books
and then two years later we're gonna see
that in the theater so a commentary on
Batman and Superman and a universe where
Batman and Superman exist fascinating in
2021 we actually had a Superman in The
Authority book and I think that's going
to be a factor so that world of an
anti-justice Justice League alongside
the suicide I think is going to be fun
we're going to play with next up we got
the Brave and the ball this is the
Batman movie that is gonna be about the
bat family I think it's very smart to
bring in Damian Wayne because Damian
Wayne effectively ages up your Batman
and puts Batman in a different position
also the darkness of Damian Wayne being
an assassin allows for us to have a
lighter Bruce Wayne I've said time and
time again I think the patents in Batman
very very importantly stay over here I
love that Universe I'm so excited about
the Universe I would sacrifice most
universes for that universe but with
this choice of Batman we get to have the
patents in darkness the brooding the
thing that wouldn't really work to have
Green Lantern Land in it frankly with a
lighter Batman that is going to be more
applicable to the Justice League because
of Damian Wayne that also establishes a
Nightwing that's probably gonna exist
perhaps a red hood it builds out the bat
family that so many people are wanting
for so long and perhaps as I've said
Adam West ish tone not that far but a
closer to Adam Weston perhaps Nolan it's
going to be a little lighter for Batman
because he's a parent next up we've got
Supergirl woman of tomorrow this is the
one I'm probably most excited for when
this is my biggest pop the whole
presentation Supergirl wonderbo tomorrow
is based off one of my favorite comic
runs of all time tonkit Tom King is one
of my favorite writers ever he wrote one
of my favorite Batmans he wrote my
favorite Supergirl today which is one of
tomorrow and I'm pretty sure he's
actually writing this movie he's been
tweeting a lot about all the Hollywood
stuff he's been working on and he's one
of the best writers in the game Mr
Miracle is Bar None my favorite DC Book
you heard me Frank Miller's everything I
love Mr Miracle that's a Tom King book
so it leans very recent but what it is
is an almost Star Wars s scope intake
hail tail and scope what it does is it
takes Supergirl off planet and she's a
very isolated individual she was born on
an asteroid she knows the trauma of loss
she has missed out on the part of
Superman that is ma and pop Kent raising
him she doesn't have that love and she's
still a hero so I love that she's able
to overcome the isolation and she's a
little more brushed for it so she's a
little bit more of a badass she's she's
the version of a character that some
other people might want more but without
the next snapping so I'm really excited
for her to be able to be a little more
Brusque and grow as a character and the
whole story is about her not letting
someone else strike Vengeance there's a
little girl that is orphaned that wants
to strike Vengeance on this alien and
basically she's like I will shoulder the
burden of killing someone you're an
innocent little girl and she rides a
badass horse because she's able to get
there flyer even though she can fly
fantastic books only eight issues very
accessible just sold out on Amazon today
I'm very proud of that book Swamp Thing
is going to be I think the boldest swing
for DC because I think this allows for a
full-on horror movie I think this is
going to be DC having all these hard
directors in their slate as a very
useful tool it looks like though James
Mangold it looks like he he did share it
in Instagram post at like midnight the
night of and I would love to just hear
from the producer of Slither and the
director of Logan on a movie I think
that's going to be a fantastic Duo to
make a movie I think they're going to
lean a lower budget and I think that's
also a strength of a lot of this late
short of Supergirl and Superman you can
make these for a lower budget which is
going to be very good for zazzilov
turning things around financially and I
think it's going to be very good to show
James Gunn's ability to profit if you
make an 80 million dollar James Mann
gold-directed Swamp Thing That Makes 300
million dollars that is a bigger profit
than perhaps doing a 300 million pump
thing so I want very practical I want
very existential they reference the Alan
Moore run which I'd highly recommend
it's a very trippy a journey into what
reality is and I think it very much
suits this new DC Universe we've also
got Creature Commandos hold on a second
we've also got Creature Commandos which
is the most obscure of these to me I
didn't actually know this title but it
looks like he's doing what he did with
Guardians of the Galaxy this isn't from
one run run of Guardians nor are those
characters this isn't for one run of
Creature Commandos he gathered his own
Greatest Hits so the Bride of
Frankenstein seems to be the leader I'm
very excited to see more about this team
and I'm really curious about how obscure
of a character set this becomes for fans
of that title that I don't know Waller I
think is going to be a peacemaker
spin-off that ties in again the world
they're building out with wildstorm I do
think this is going to be a cameo-tastic
world and I also think this is going to
be a really fun journey into the
psychology of Waller we had Peacemaker
get likable I think it's time for Waller
to get like well lanterns this is
described as True Detective and I think
this is going to be basically Hal Jordan
passing the torch over to Jon Stewart
and this being a mystery that ties in
the whole greater universe and a True
Detectives gonna be fascinating and I
also think it's going to establish a
terrestrial take that's going to end
with him going out to outer space and
people wanting Green Lantern for a very
long time I think there's a lot of
stakes in this choice and I think having
a water cooler conversation show like
True Detective on HBO's smart it'll be
like last of us where we all talk about
it every week we need a lantern show and
we need them to be about Justice in a
very unique and interesting way Booster
Gold is probably the most topical of all
these shows this is a show about people
basically a guy coming back from the
future and using future Tech in a way
that he is able to basically be a hero
by default so this guy is smarmy he's
attention seeking he's a bit of a douche
but I think that's going to be very
interesting in The Tick Tock world where
a lot of people do stuff for clout I
want to see a character that is
basically trying to be a hero in the
eyes of people just by being famous I
think it's very topical I think it's
going to lean into the insecurities of
the world today and I think it's going
to be very very 20 25. and then finally
Paradise Lost is a take on the mascara
there are a couple Comics that are
actually about the amazonians without
Diana it seems like this is going to be
building out a Game of Thrones s world
and I think it's going to build the
tapestry of DC more than build an
individual character but it does give us
an interesting opportunity for Nubia and
other Wonder Woman type characters to
build out this world I think the Slate
was genius for overall World building
and I'm actually more excited for a lot
of this than I expected to be my
expectations run at 11 and it gave me a
15. I think it leaves a lot older and I
think it leans a lot more mature and I
think it's going to get people to
actually read Comics because he's
presented them with Comics thank you
James Gunn I'm very excited well that
was wow that was great
to be on the break room yesterday he
said no so we only gave him six minutes
today and thank you uh koi for risking
your heart health okay uh tune in
tomorrow at the same time we're gonna
have a awful awful Redemption tomorrow
so be sure to be there be here for that
like And subscribe thanks for watching
today Thomas got his breakdown of the
first three episodes of the bad batch
coming out on the channel now I said let
it rip and Eric's doing a big uh coming
out tomorrow talking about some of the
deleted scenes for The Last of Us uh but
we hope you join us here tomorrow we
hope you've had a great Thursday check
out nerd riot.chap uh and we'll see you
here tomorrow late Escape have a good
evening
[Music]
thank you
it's true